I disagree with you on a couple points
Ben sure I'm personally introduce myself
my name is cash Jackson I'm a retired
Navy veteran and thank you for your
service thank you
I am also intending on running for
governor 2018 here in the state of
Illinois and I wanted to specifically
address where you spoke about
victimization and people coming from
impoverished neighborhoods that that
poverty wasn't kind of that what you
equated to for criminal activity and
that addressing crime by putting more
police into these inner-city communities
would be the resolution to set criminal
activity I just want to challenge that
thought process on a couple of points
sure beginning with my personal opinion
and some of this is going to be rooted
in facts and others just in my
observation is that the majority of
crime that's being committed in these
inner-city neighborhoods if we look at
prison statistics if we look at gang
violence we look at drug abuse we look
at teen pregnancy suicide and depression
amongst our youth there's one common
denominator that common denominator is
that these children are growing up in
fatherless homes they're going they're
growing up and follow those homes not
because fathers are not present and
because we have a plethora of deadbeat
father's which has been painted through
the social through the media that
there's millions of deadbeat father's
out there that's simply not the truth
what is the truth is that the states
have found it profitable by
misappropriating title 4d funding
through the Social Security Act from the
federal government down to the states
the states
take a parent which is historically and
statistically the father they relegate
them down to a visitor during a custody
proceeding such as my case so I hope
that you can smear this over your
website they reduce me down to a visitor
status to justify a child support order
when they do that and they force that
collection process they receive federal
funding directly to the state a so sorry
I don't want to break up the long
paragraphs there but it but it's um but
you know more about custody battles an
item
I will just say that obviously custody
battles only take place in a situation
in which there's a conflict between the
spouses I mean I assume that you and
your spouse don't get along great well I
mean let me finish just addressing I
know I'm long-winded sorry one more one
more comment the fact is that it is not
custody battles the custody battles are
not the reason 70 percent of black kids
are born out of wedlock and 40 percent
of white kids are born out of wedlock
it's because people having the sex out
of wedlock and having babies but but
when that child support order is put in
place okay in order to justify the
support order they they have to take one
parent which historically is the father
and say you're only going to get every
other weekend and when we do that we
have set the stage for emotional and
mental challenges for those individuals
and again if you look at teen pregnancy
statistics drug abuse statistics so I
agree with you about the correlation
between all these terrible things in
single motherhood I just disagree with
you statistically that cases of father
visit a visitation in divorce cases
represent the even even a large minority
of the cases of single motherhood again
the vast majority of if we're talking
about the what the the sort of culture
of single motherhood that's been
creating the United States it is not
about custody hearings it is about the
fact that people are getting pregnant
before they're married out of wedlock
and having babies without a father even
in the home this is not to diminish the
problems in custody battles there's no
question that a lot of custody law is
biased toward the mother that's been
true for for thirty years forty years
fifty years but to pretend that that is
the main problem facing inner-city
communities for example ignores the fact
that the vast majority people who are
having babies out of wedlock are having
an out of wedlock they're not having an
in wedlock and then dad is taking off
dad's taking off because they never got
married okay this is why marriage is a
prerequisite I believe then that if you
look at say the south side chicago and
the west side chicago if you look at
that in the crime that is there today
you can trace that back to Jim Crow to
the war on drugs to mass incarceration
and when fathers were taken out in large
numbers over a long duration you now
have set the stage where you have so
many children being had out of
Wenlock because the family unit has
broken down in these know the increase
in single motherhood is not based in Jim
Crow because the fact is that at the end
of Jim Crow this is the black single
motherhood right was twenty percent
today it's seventy two percent okay so
to the society get more racist how did
that happen is it just a ticking time
bomb that they left under the kitchen
table the fact is that people are having
babies out of wedlock now because there
are government structures in place that
basically incentivize people to have
babies out of wedlock and that's and
that's the real problem now in terms of
crime obviously crime is involved the
single motherhood what I'm suggesting is
that there are two ways to tackle this
problem one is a broader cultural
critique in which we say to people you
need to get married and that means
getting people involved in church and
synagogue getting people involved in a
social network that encourages people to
get married before they have babies
that's a long term project because it
takes a hunter it takes a hundred years
for an entire society to devolve to the
point where a majority of babies are
being born out of wedlock in the
community or a vast minority in the
white community that's one way to tackle
it a shorter term way to tackle crime is
to put all the criminals in prison
because again I think that that sets off
a chain reaction that's actually good
and the chain reaction is then now you
can have businesses invest I'm not going
to take my money and invest in a store
that I think is going to be robbed
tomorrow because the crime rate is high
I'm only going to invest where I think
the cops are going to protect and if
there are no cops there to protect it's
hard for me to invest once I invest that
creates a property tax base or a local
taxation base and now you actually have
the money if you want a good public
school to actually put together a good
public school so all of these things
need to be need to happen at once but
the only quarrel I have with you at all
is is I think that you're taking in
anecdote and expanding it out
statistically where that's not actually
statistically valid that the federal
incentives to the states for the states
to receive federal funding based on
their force collection of child support
no I'm not arguing with you on that you
may be very well be right I don't know
enough about that to answer that
question all I'm saying is that if
you're talking about child support as
the as the lead problem in in these
communities there we disagree I mean
sorry have to move on so there's a lot
of other questions
hi I just wanna say thank you for your
talk today and that's coming from
someone who disagrees with basically
everything you say oh good I'm glad yeah
so thank you for coming so today you had
a Twitter thread in response to Ted
Lou's comments on health insurance and
the CBO report that yeah now about why
pre-existing conditions should be
charged more for those with pre-existing
conditions that become priced out of the
market due to them being charged more
which I understand your reasoning behind
you know car insurance stuff like that I
read I mean I mean to reiterate minded
my point people who don't understand
just so if you're coming in late to this
conversations head Lou tweeted something
out about how it's ridiculous basically
for insurance companies to charge people
with pre-existing conditions more so
which I said it's an insurance company
of course it does I mean every insurance
company in history charges people more
based on their risk profile that's why
you have risk Assessors at insurance
companies so go ahead yeah my question
is for the people who are priced out of
the market
yeah due to that you know is their only
solution to go without health care and
why do you think that's an acceptable
solution when most other nations have
found us no I don't think that's an
acceptable solution I think what we need
to do is we've trained now three
generations of Americans to be dependent
on the government to fill that gap so
there are a couple of ways that you can
that you can tackle these issues the the
chief problem and I think we all
acknowledge this is that people don't
buy it let's say that everyone were age
zero for a second okay everyone was born
today how do you solve the health care
problem you don't really have to solve
the healthcare problem because people
presumably you train them to buy
insurance when they're young the big
problem is people don't buy insurance
when they're young now they're 60 they
don't have insurance they have
pre-existing conditions and now no one's
gonna cover them right so we all know
that the the problem in the future is
not gonna be people who are 65 because
in 50 years 40 years 30 years they'll be
dead all right the big problem is going
to be people who are 20 who are not
getting health insurance now and then in
40 years they have a pre-existing
condition they look for health insurance
so if we're talking about the future and
the future plans for health care what we
need to be doing is encouraging young
people to buy health insurance well
they're only two ways to do that one is
to use the government to force people to
buy health insurance and the other way
is to basically have a market system
that punishes people for not buying
health insurance okay the way you have a
market system that punishes people for
not buying health insurance is you make
it very clear to people that there's a
moral hazard involved here that if you
don't buy health insurance that you're
going to be paying more in the long run
so you'd better well pay
health insurance right now and make
smart decisions about it now for the
people who fall through the cracks as I
say there there's there's two groups now
that we're talking about there's people
who are old and have pre-existing
conditions and it's too late for them
what do we do they can't go back to
being 20 and buy health insurance when
they were healthy right so for those
people obviously we have to have some
sort of backup that phases out over time
right that doesn't work the same way for
a 60 year old as it works for a 40 year
old or a 30 year old who can buy when
they're healthy because we want to
encourage those people to buy not to be
relying on government and their I'm not
I'm not against the idea of a phased out
government program based on age that
help subsidize people in pre-existing
condition situations and the other thing
is that you have to have private charity
pick up the slack for a lot of this
stuff and this is where I've said that I
think that private charity does pick up
the slack for a lot of things I mean you
know Jimmy Kimmel made obviously a big
to-do when he did a when he did a
routine on his on his show in which he
talked about how his baby son had been
born they took him to Children's
Hospital he had an open-heart surgery
and and that's why you need Obamacare
okay Jimmy Kimmel didn't have Obamacare
Jimmy Kimmel had private insurance the
fact is the private insurance which
covers the vast majority of the market
is still covering of pre-existing
conditions because when you are employed
and you have insurance you're pooled
with all the other employees of your
company that's the way it works right
they don't charge you more with a
pre-existing condition at least in huge
numbers when you when you're getting it
through your employer
so the problem so that's prominent with
Jimmy Kimmel is he already had health
insurance the problem number two that
you didn't mention is the Children's
Hospital is a Charity Hospital a lot of
people are coming in there with Medicaid
and the only way that people can get
covered is not just through Medicaid
it's because there's a bunch of charity
that's coming in and supplementing the
Medicaid to pay the doctor I know this
because the doctor who operated on Jimmy
Kimmel son is gonna involve art and he
operated on my daughter when she was a
year and half old
so we were at the same hospital but the
same doctor the vast majority of
patients there I believe we're on
Medicaid and they were able to get care
because of the charity that was involved
so my solutions are twofold four there's
a long answer to but it's a complex
question so the so the the answer is one
private charity needs to be increased so
that we can help pick up the slack
because if that doesn't happen
conservatives note to us we need to give
more charity because if we don't do it
the government's gonna try to okay and
solution number two is that we have to
have a stout program that takes care of
the people for whom it's too late to
actually make good decisions but still
encourages people to make good decisions
now about buying their insurance which
means there must be a risk
attached to not buying insurance comment
um two things first of all if you're
encouraging people to buy health
insurance you know at the age of twenty
or an age like that they're not gonna
have you know the income or the
percentage to donate as much to a better
insurance plan you know you don't need a
terrific insurance plan when you're 20
you know the catastrophic insurance plan
when you're 20 and then the truth is
that most of the time you need a
catastrophic insurance plan generally
you shouldn't have to go to insurance
company if you have a flu you should be
able go to doctor and pay cash and also
when you're 20 there are still people
with pre-existing conditions that would
jack up those costs and getting it early
might not help 100% but again this is a
time lapse question because the fact is
that you know my daughter was covered
under my insurance right if you're if
you're under 20 you're covered on your
parent's insurance typically so thank
you hi mr. Shapiro thank you for being
here today I'm sure it takes guts to say
those things especially place like
Northwestern so thank you
oh it's fine I do it for a living so so
you mentioned a couple times about how
there needs to be a national dialogue
focusing on various social issues do you
think that your your caustic left versus
right liberal versus conservative
language helps to change people's views
or do you think that your success your
fame this tour that you're doing comes
from being a sounding board for people
who already have established you use
very similar to yours so I think some
above so I will agree that that some of
the things that I say are costing one of
the reasons that I do this in caustic
matter is because if you're entertaining
people then you're also getting them to
listen to you we live in an
entertainment culture and all of that is
true the second thing is the reason that
I do that is because the Contin the most
common left argument against people on
the right is you're mean you're nasty
you're cruel you're bad it's not an
argument it's a character attack by me
getting aggressive that basically says
to the left okay back off we're not
gonna make character attacks on each
other because we can do it all day now
we can have a discussion so you may have
noticed that the last couple of people
who came up are people who disagree with
me and we've had a very cordial
discussion I'm more than happy to have
cordial discussions but first we have to
take off the table the idea that I'm an
because you disagree with me so
the way to do that is by me saying
listen if you think that and that kind
of makes you an so that's the
that's it that's the way that I do that
is to disarm the character argument so
we can actually get
brass tacks again I think that the
evidence is pretty good that I've
convinced you know this is not on me
it's because people listen thank God is
that I've convinced a fair number of
people I mean I do get dozens of letters
a day from people on the left who've
listened to my arguments and it's caused
them to at least think a little bit more
deeply about the argument there's room
for a lot of various voices with a lot
of various different approaches I mean
you can approach it like Arthur Brooks
and that's wonderful I love Arthur
Brooks but there needs to be somebody
who is who says some of the tough things
that people aren't willing to hear and
that's not just about me saying in the
caustic fashion it's about me saying
things that people don't want to hear
like people take it as caustic when I
say your life is in your hands that
seems to me not a particularly caustic
thing to say but people get offended by
it because it's something they don't
necessarily want to hear when I say when
I say things like you know if you're
living in if you're employed by an
industry where there are jobs that are
being lost to technology trumping gonna
bring it back Hillary I'm gonna bring it
back
nobody's gonna bring it back when I say
that people get very upset because they
want people to bring it back but that's
not me being caustic it's the facts
being caustic do you think that you said
people like to characterize you as an
do you think that's just because
not just my wife yeah do you think
that's because that was just a very
personal attack on your character is
that's based on your views well I think
that it's because of my views that they
attack my character I mean I think that
yeah I like to think that I'm a
relatively a nice guy but the fact is
that it doesn't matter how nice you are
Mitt Romney was a genial fellow and they
called him a guy who straps dogs the top
of his cars wants to put y'all back in
Chains and and his binders full of women
because he hates women
right there there's not a more genial
person in politics more kind-hearted
kind of genteel person in politics than
Mitt Romney and they basically called
them Hitler and that's why they spent
that bullet by the time from came around
who legitimately is not the world's
greatest guy
good evening mr. Shapiro howdy I just
want to say thank you for everything you
do I don't have a question for besides
this I wouldn't know if you would sign
your book yeah bring up her analysis and
if and if I could just shake my hand
okay
I'm always happy to shake hands along
[Applause]
hi Ben this is a Twitter question from
Cairo cuz it says when was the last time
you changed her mind on some public
policy and why did you make that change
so I changed my mind based on further
evidence so the last time that I
remember changing my mind was on
decriminalization of marijuana so I used
to be in favor of criminalization of
marijuana my views have shifted very
libertarian on the drug war and that's
because as I saw more evidence that the
drug wars a giant fail and that fit with
my general worldview which the
government sucks at everything except
breaking things then now what no don't
mistake my my lack of support for the
drug war for my for my support for drugs
people who smoke pot irritate me to an
enormous degree and I think they're
wasting time and brain cells but with
that said that's it that's a case where
I think that the as the evidence makes
itself clear it's pretty clear the
government doesn't know what to do with
the with the war on marijuana and
they've wasted a lot of time and money
and and have heard a lot of people in
that war
so my question just sort of focuses on
two sort of different things you've been
talking about one which is focusing on
the decisions people make and how that
influences how successful they are and
two you made a comment saying in America
we don't afford you you know equality
well things like that we give you
equality of access well equal access to
rights not not equal access
okay there is a difference what I mean
by equal access to rights obviously is I
mean that no one's gonna get in your way
that the rights that you hold are the
same as the rights that I hold but when
I'm say and and if somebody blocks them
then that's blocking your access but
what I don't mean is that a person who
has a million dollars in the bank is
equally situated with a person with five
dollars in the bank is obviously that's
stupid yes and I would agree that that's
stupid
good one agreements on stupidity yeah
something we can agree on so III do want
to sort of extend that into I I do
personally believe that the number one
factor and a lot of these sort of things
are the decisions you make but a lot of
what affects your decisions is sort of
where you start out and sometimes that's
like a long sort of cultural argument
and things like that for other times
it's something more basic like well if
you weren't born into as wealthy a
family it's harder to go to a nicer
college and you're pressured to take
another job so you don't finish high
school or you have to take care of you
know it's a single-parent household
which you didn't decide your parents
made poor decision yes but then you have
to take care of your little siblings or
things like that so then it becomes
harder for you to maintain your job and
you lose that so I think there's a lot
of sort of things that hundred percent
this is correct yeah three sort of key
tickets you've talked about that are
heavily influenced by factors entirely
out of a person well I mean not having
babies out of wedlock is definitely not
influenced by factors beyond your
control I mean unless you have
uncontrollable genitalia so that's so
you know the so the fact is that just
because you had a single mom doesn't
mean that you have to follow in the
pattern bottom line is that when you
have cycles of poverty somebody's gonna
have to break that at some point that's
gonna take an act of will when it comes
to graduating from high school the
number of people who are dropping out of
high school because they need to you
know support their family is incredibly
low in the United States but if that's
the case then you know I I'll give you
an example there's a there's a listener
of mine who's a young woman think she's
probably 18 years old who emailed me the
other day and she said you have your
three rules right no don't have babies
before marriage and and get finish high
school and then get a job and she said I
love your show I agree with everything
you say I also broke one of those rules
so I have a baby I had a baby when I was
fifteen years old and what should I do
about that and I said well I replied her
I said well what's your social structure
like why did you have a new parents
nearby who can help out with your kid
you have a church that you belong to
people who you can rely on and she said
well I'm not really a member of a church
I don't have like a huge social
structure and my mom my mom's also a
single mom because there are these
pathologies where there are generations
of single mothers and and so what should
I do and she said well I went ahead
my GED and now I'm trying to go to
Community College but I don't have money
for childcare I don't have money for
childcare my mom works so what should I
do and I said well why don't you put
together a GoFundMe and get it to me and
I'll push it out there and so she sent
me a GoFundMe I put a hundred bucks in
the kitty an hour and a half later she
had $6,000
the reason that I did that and the
reason I tell this story is not because
I'm such a wonderful dude although I am
the reason that I the reason that I tell
this story is because there is a world
of willing people who are willing to
give and help you escape these things if
you want to make the effort there's
whole groups of people out there there's
whole organizations dedicated to helping
you escape making bad decisions
dedicated to helping you get out of
poverty and if people need to find these
things then please email me email your
church email your synagogue there are
entire religions dedicated to this and
this idea that these are their these
inescapable chains of poverty the no
decision you make can help you escape
these things you know if that's true
then we're not doing good enough job on
a private level but I don't think it's
true I think the American people are the
most generous people on the face of the
earth statistically speaking that is
eminently true Republicans by the way do
give much more money to charity than
Democrats mainly because they're
religious
and and so our goal as individuals not
as a society because I don't like to
talk about our goals as a quote/unquote
society our goals as individuals should
be to help people make the right
decision so they can escape these these
bad decisions that they were about to
make and other end people's goals as
individuals should also be not to make
the bad decisions these at these these
cycles cannot be broken by a government
coming in and trying to fix them
government tried to fix poverty in 1964
and the war on poverty has now been
going for half a century and by
percentage the same number of people are
poor okay so this is just not working
we're gonna need to do something else
and it's gonna need to come down to
individual decision making just to end
this I want to thank you for your
personal kind charity especially I
didn't give you money I can thank you
for your kindness to others and I am
very appreciative of everyone who does
that I just personally don't believe
that that's going to be the solution for
everyone out there but once again I I
thank you for coming and speaking here
and
thank you for advancing the cause of
charity even if you do it in a way that
is politically different from my own
well thank you I appreciate that
[Applause]
what do you view as the consequence of
the left taking power in America well I
mean I think the the if I haven't made
this clear I think that you know when
you're talking about the left taking
power of the government the consequence
is more intervention in our lives more
regulation more redistribution of wealth
the left has a basic view of the
government which is that the government
is there to guarantee positive rights
and what they mean by positive rights is
taking something from someone and giving
it to someone else so a positive right
to health care let me say right to
health care they mean forcing my wife to
provide health care and a price that she
doesn't want to provide and they've been
putting a gun to somebody's head and
then threatening them that's that the
the government is a big pointing the gun
at somebody machine that's what the
government does and so when the left
takes control of that then the
government can either point that gun at
people who are getting in the way of
your exercise of your right so the
government can point it at somebody else
and forced them to guarantee you things
and the left is about pointing the gun
at people and forcing them to guarantee
you things and that holds true on
everything from religious freedom which
will be quashed to redistribution ISM to
government regulation on a whole variety
of issues hi Ben thanks for coming out
I'm just kind of curious I know we you
mentioned the I see a speaker who came
in and got protested out but yes you're
us what's your particular stance on the
way we handle undocumented immigrants in
this country because I'm aware that they
aren't US citizens they don't have
constitutional rights but they are still
people and we should treat them with
respect they have human dignity so what
are your thoughts okay so let me start
from this premise my view on immigration
is almost entirely libertarian if there
are no welfare state
so my view on immigration is that free
flow of labor is a good thing but there
are two mitigating factors mitigating
factor number one is you can't come here
to take advantage of the welfare systems
and mitigating factor number two is you
have to accept the culture of the United
States which is to say the rights that
are expressed in the Constitution and
Declaration of Independence which means
a small government not guaranteeing
bigger services through redistribution
of income but you know that we don't
have to people come here to work we
don't have to given the vote either I
mean as long as you're coming here not
committing a crime and you just want to
work I don't really see that as being a
particularly big problem as far as
people who aren't undocumented and
violating the law to be here the biggest
problem is I see it
is again twofold one is taking advantage
of the welfare system and there is a net
cost for people who are coming here
illegally because they take advantage of
the education system for example they
take advantage of state systems it's
still forbidden to get federal welfare
but their state systems in California
where I live there are tremendous state
support systems for undocumented
immigrants illegal immigrants and and so
here's my view the government has every
right to decide who comes in the country
and who doesn't come into the country
that is true for new immigrants it's
true for people who are already here
if you come here and we feel that your
net benefit to the citizens of the
United States you're coming in here and
you are going to work hard and fly right
and you're gonna be a great addition to
the United States you respect our view
of human nature and of government and
you just want to be part of this great
mission then more power to you come on
in I the same thing holds true friends
documents and immigrants just because
you've been here for ten years if you've
been if you've been relying on welfare
and then I think you ought to go if you
are not a net benefit to the United
States you ought to go a citizenry gets
to say who gets to join and who doesn't
get to join and you know if that is if
that means that there's a father and a
mother and the father is a bad addition
but the mother is a good addition then
they're gonna have to make a family
decision as to where they live just like
we would have to in any other family
situation but it seems weird to me that
the government can go through 150
million tax forms every year that the
government doesn't have the power to go
through 11 million applications from
illegal immigrants interview people and
decide who's going to add to the country
economically and culturally and who's
going to detract so in other words do it
on an individual level the big problem
is that you have people on both sides
who don't want to do it on an individual
level they want to say okay all on
document all illegal images on documents
because that's a euphemism all the
illegal immigrants out okay I think
that's silly there are people who are
illegal immigrants who have been here
working hard and doing the right things
but there are lots of people who haven't
and people on the Left who say everybody
should stay because they've been here
and they're just like us well not
everybody is just like us and we should
take that into account
hi Ben my name is also Ben that's about
it that's all we have in common you
spoke a lot about how the crime and a
lot of issues in America come with
having sex out of wedlock and having
basically broken up families
I was wondering your opinion on mass
incarceration in this country and how
that affects entice into victimization
specifically related to black and brown
people but I'll get there in a second
America has 25% of the world's prison
population with 5% of the world's
population so obviously a lot of your
families where kids go wrong they don't
have the support systems that's why
their fathers or their mothers are in
prison and you can look at very concrete
examples of ways where the law has not
been applied equally to black versus
white people so one example of that is
in 1986 the anti-drug Abuse Act where
they punished crack cocaine which black
people used more than white people at a
hundred-to-one rate which was recently
reduced to 18 to 1 under Barack Obama so
I don't see how you can claim that
everyone is treating equally and no one
is victimized on a systemic level when
you have laws that punish one race that
is more likely to use one type of drug
more than in another race when it's
actually been shown that among kids our
age white people and suburban kids are
more likely to use drugs in schools than
black inner-city kids ok so there's a
lot there and you're right we disagree
on everything so so to begin with I
don't believe in the concept of mass
incarceration because that implies that
the police are going into black
communities with lasso rounding people
up and taking them to jail for no reason
I don't think that's happening every
person who is in jail has had a trial or
a plea the idea that people are just
being grabbed and thrown into prison to
keep alive some sort of prison
industrial complex where the the prison
masters are the ones running the system
I don't see evidence of that as far as
the 1986 law I think that it's important
to put this into context and the context
is that that law was originally pressed
by black legislators from inner cities
who are sick of watching crack cocaine
destroying their communities and the
reason for the despair
is because crack was more easily
distributable and significantly more
effective than powder cocaine it is also
the fact that the vast majority of
people who are distributing and using
crack cocaine or black you know it's a
drug that the vast majority of people
who distribute and use are white crystal
meth guess what the penalty is for one
ounce of crystal meth versus one ounce
of crack cocaine they are identical they
are identical because they are easily
distributed and they are distributed in
similar forms so the idea that this was
just some sort of attempt to grab black
people off the street and throw them in
jail for no reason so we could have a
permanent underclass of people with no
fathers this seems to me like a giant
conspiracy theory with little evidence
to support it as far as the idea that
that these communities we'd better if we
just release people onto the streets so
I think it's important again to note the
statistics here the fact is the vast
vast vast vast vast majority of people
who are in jail or in jail for drug
crimes are in for distribution not
merely for use the idea that it's a
black kid who's just smoking crack on
the street who's getting picked up by
the cops and thrown in jail the justice
system doesn't have time for that
okay the vast majority of even
possessions that are pled down from
distributions no I've said earlier I'm
not in favor of the drug war okay but I
can tell you something the people who
are currently acting in criminal fashion
and the drug war aren't going to be out
acting as model citizens as a general
rule a lot of those people are going to
be committing other crimes because this
is in the history of the United States
when you make a substance illegal the
people who are criminals were criminals
before and they're criminals after Al
Capone was not going to turn into a
banker after prohibition ended and the
same thing is true for a lot of the
people who are committing criminal acts
by distributing illicit substances so I
think that to pretend that the epidemic
of single motherhood is going to end all
these guys were just gonna decide you
know what I've decided to marry that
girl I'm gonna stay home it's gonna be
Leave It to Beaver when they were
dealing crack on the corner to
twelve-year-old kids the day before I
think that's a little bit of a myth yeah
I want to respond to one specific point
you were saying the idea that cops are
going into black communities and
lassoing of black people is completely
ridiculous how would you explain the
amount of black people in jail currently
higher numbers of black people
committing crimes
that's not the case it is absolutely the
case there's it's been statistically
shown that white people use drugs just
as much as and as I said people are
generally not arrested for using drugs
they're generally arrested for drug
distribution in the drug war
white people not distribute drugs well
they don't
in terms of proportionality with regard
to I mean the idea that again you need
to show me the statistics on drug
distribution so the burden is on you to
prove the disparity not on me to prove
the non disparity well you're the one
who's accusing the criminal justice
system of Wilde and justice again I
don't have the statistics in front of me
so it's hard for me to cite statistics
on that particular aspect of drug
distribution but you'd have to show that
there are a bunch of white people who
are distributing drugs to the same
extent as the black people in jail and
then telling me that they're not being
treated equally you can't just suggest
that drug use is equal to drug
distribution because statistically it's
not alright so I just wanted to start by
thanking the College Republicans young
America's Foundation Ben Shapiro as uh
as like an immigrant a Muslim fairly
liberal person I think it's probably the
best event that I've been able to access
just because I'm not sitting in the
audience and nodding for an hour well
thank you I appreciate it
yes I really do appreciate the platform
for free dialog I think it's extremely
important for there to be free speech so
the good ideas sort of crowd out the bad
ones
the reason I'm kind of here today is
because you know while I was sitting
there and I've noticed this in a lot of
your your videos which I do spend some
time watching well thank you I
appreciate it definitely entertaining
yeah so um so like you know like yeah I
like yesterday right before coming here
before I slept I watched you on Piers
Morgan talking about gun control you
know I heard you for an hour today and I
think what I realized is it's I think
the first step is talking about free
speech and I think the left can
definitely work on that the second step
is is using solid sound I guess evidence
for your speech so that truly you have
good ideas crowding out the bad and I
just wanted to take issue with a few
things that you mentioned that I felt
were a bit more sensational a bit more I
guess I know you're from like a lawyer
background so I can see no go for it I'm
yeah so like you mentioned for rape on
college campuses from 1995 to 2002 as a
statistic you used because those are the
last available statistics from sure sure
so current statistics that you think
have I guess methods that are
you know unjustified because it's
self-identified but that's contemporary
and you're looking at something that
started 20 but 20 years ago and then
making up for the caveat that okay it's
it's a self-identified so it might not
actually reach them out so what I'm
saying is clearly we don't have sound
data on this and and maybe not all of
the self-identified reports are
justified but using a statistic that's
20 years old even if it's the most
contemporary one that you have is I
think unsound in terms of academics so I
agree with you I'd like to have better
statistics now let me ask you a question
on that do you think that the rape rate
in the United States on college campuses
is closer to six in 1,000 or 250 in
1,000
- Utley it's somewhere in between and I
don't think I know but I mean like if
you had to if you had to try and pick a
number I mean I understand that I'm
putting on the spot a little bit here
sure sure yeah like a scientist as
Titian and I don't claim to posture to
be and I don't think you should either
if you don't have statistics you think
that it has increased 10,000 thing is
for you to criticize a certain community
of using a statistic one out of five as
sensational because the people who
actually created that statistic say that
it's being misused sure and you're using
a statistic that's 20 years old because
it's the best statistic available again
if you're willing to give me better
statistics I'm more than willing to hear
them and as I've said if you provide me
new evidence I'm more than willing to
change my mind no I mean I don't think I
have the political knowledge to debate
that so like just a couple things I'm
moving forward I think you talked about
I don't know you said like you mentioned
Jim Crow laws and slavery for what kind
of pushed black people back and you said
okay this is in the past again this is
an example of taking the the
opposition's argument making a character
of it and dropping it down real fast
everyone knows about Jim Crow everyone
knows about slavery not as many people
know about
for example redlining in the Chicago in
Chicago in the 1960s that CVL had to
push out by 1964 the these kinds of
systems have been entrenched for years I
think most people have read Tennessee
Coates article and on how this has
developed a you know system have been
entrenchment for these communities even
today under Rahm Emmanuel who's a
Democrat and I think is wrong implements
TIF increment financing that takes money
out of western and southern Chicago and
reappropriation to places that don't
really need it as much clearly there's a
lack of funding he closed 47 schools
over the past years what I'm basically
trying to say is there's a lot of
factors going on in these come
these that are predominantly black
Hispanic etc and for you to simply say
that okay Jim Crow happened fifty years
ago
racism has an increase is a bit I think
again insincere because I don't believe
that racism has I do believe that racism
has decrease in you know yeah we're
saying the n-word less sure but I don't
think that racism at a systemic level
has decreased because the same
communities that were affected in the
1960s you know those people are still
alive I said that's a wild accusation I
mean that like I'm with you all the way
up till the end well when you say
there's a lot of complexity of these
arguments I agree there's a lot of
complexity of these arguments I'll tell
you where there is no complexity and
that is the only way you are going to
get out of the current problems that you
are in is by relying on yourself to make
the decisions that's not to say that
there aren't obstacles and if there are
obstacles that you can name I'm more
than happy to stand there and fight them
with you can you show me evidence of
redlining by a bank in which a black
person and a white person are being
treated unequally with exactly the same
application I will stand next to you and
root for them to be prosecuted in court
because that's illegal
under the Civil Rights Act but if you're
going to suggest that racism has not
decreased over the last 50 years it's
just sort of hidden there is no evidence
to suggest that whatsoever sorry I
misspoke
so I grew that was my dad I don't think
racism has increases absolutely
decreased but I think that the
institutions that existed 50 years ago
haven't really vanished the title
character of the Atlantic story clyde
ross i went to his house you know he is
experiencing the same things that
experience 50 years ago the government
will come by and i know you say that the
government should fix this and I agree
I'm just saying the government shouldn't
make it worse the government comes by
they say hey we're providing subsidies
for these communities to become better
you can use it for paint for your house
better windows anything that the the
like the public can see to make it look
better but he doesn't have a heating in
his house well you can't use it for that
because that's just not the system
that's in place right all I'm saying is
the government's out yeah I totally
agree with you on that but all I'm
trying to say so come to the dark side
right I guess all I'm trying to say is I
definitely agree that these are
complicated I think the left and the
right they take small points and they
sensationalize them to create a
political platform I would just
appreciate it since you are a journalist
and not a politician to the same kind of
you know due diligence when you really
like offer input because a lot of people
listen to you a lot of people respect
you well okay so it's so again the
article that you're citing bite on he
goes I haven't actually read that
article so I'm not gonna claim knowledge
of an article that you've read and I
have it so I'll take your account of the
situation for what it is which is
there's some guy who is apparently being
victimized by the government because the
government will only give him subsidies
for X Y & Z but he actually wants it for
a B and C my answer to that is that it's
not the government's job to provide
subsidies for anyone and if the if the
government is now appropriating
subsidies I object to that regardless of
the race of the person like I objected
subsidies to the ethanol boondoggle in
Iowa which is basically white people
object to subsidies to Wall Street
I checked all these subsidies I don't
think the government should be involved
at all and this fellow who you know was
victim that that systematized
discrimination under Jim Crow that was
happening in 1960 is the same as a badly
run government program in 2017 because
they want to give you money for your
windows but not for your water heater
again I don't see the relationship
between the two and to suggest that the
banks are operating in the same way now
as they were operating in 1960 I don't
see the evidence for that either
I'm happy to look at evidence but I need
actual evidence I can't just base it on
headlines
I've been I'm Matt I'm a big fan of your
work in particular the Ben Shapiro thug
life videos but I can't take credit for
those things yeah so I was hoping you
could just a couple things so I really
enjoyed your book bullies know a lot of
the arguments and points man they're
from I believe 2012 and in particular
the Romney Obama election yes I was
wondering if you could address how those
trends have evolved over time and in
particular if you feel the recent
presidential election was almost a
backlash against some of those trends
and then additionally I was hoping you
could talk about maybe what we as
students can help do to prevent a
culture of bullying and in particularly
to fight back against the one-sided
conversations that a lot of times even
assertion so so so brief answer I think
that with regard to the messages in
bullies I think they are certainly
apropos to current politics and I think
there was a backlash against the feeling
like people say that it was a bunch of
Trump voters in the Midwest who decided
that they were angry at the at the
current system just because the current
system was because they were poor and
people hadn't been fulfilled or whatever
I don't think that's really what
happened I think there are a bunch of
people who lived in these blue-collar
states in the Rust Belt and they said
I'm sick of being called a racist sexist
pig and homophobe at least Trump doesn't
think that I'm mean and nasty and
deplorable and therefore I'm going to
and therefore I'm voting for Trump and
there was an attempt by the Democrats to
polarize Americans along racial ethnic
sexual orientation lines and they
objected to it and so it was more of a
cultural fight I think than it was an
economic fight in fact unemployment
correlated really highly in those swing
states with voting for Hillary Clinton
not with voting for Trump as far as your
second question I'm trying to remember
what it was the reiterate for a second I
was mostly just wondering like what oh
why you can do that as students to find
out so I mean I think that the first
thing that you can do as students is
talk to people on an individual level
this doesn't mean you have to engage in
every conversation you should determine
whether our conversation is useful or
not whether someone wants to have an
honest conversation or not or whether
they're just there to beat you up or and
if they are then maybe it's good for
practice maybe it's good for you to hear
the other side so you can do it back and
forth but there's no substitute for
individual conversation because that's
how people are actually convinced and I
think even I mean you see by the number
of people who are liberals in the
audience and notice I've used left all
night I don't use liberals except for
people who actually believe there ought
to be an open discourse so thank you to
all the liberals in the audience who
showed up to
and a hand round of applause for them
because I appreciate it those are the
people who yeah you dude yeah those
those are the people who who I think you
can have an honest conversation with and
I think those are the people who are
gonna have to stand beside to fight
against some of the people who try to
shut down these debates based on
character attacks rather than merit last
question so thank you for coming out
this afternoon I had a question about
your statistics about how there's the
disproportionate amount of single
motherhood in African American
communities right right and so starting
in 1960 or 1970 with roe v-- wade we had
this boom of a legalization of abortion
which I kind of appreciate your
understanding the pro-life argument I
was very pro-choice until I heard that
and kind of maybe in that middle ground
of like yeah well I don't really really
have to do so I did some research and so
finding that when abortion was legalized
you look at Romania and then you look at
America right this is a Freakonomics
argument you saw that there was a
decrease in crime in between people
under 25 in the 1990s and so this time
made me think that maybe this is a
correlation between out of the white and
african-american communities because at
that time african-american news were
predominately low income so they didn't
have access to that form of
contraception which I think it's why we
feel that today while there is this huge
proportion of whether you're saying 70%
of single mothers are african-american
if not that's the reason I would secure
us what is the reason and then what is
the solution to that okay so I abortion
is not the reason for the drop in crime
first of all even if it were the reason
for the drop in crime is not an excuse
for killing babies so you know so that's
no more
the evidence that it's not the reason
for the drop in crime very Lasser makes
this argument in a book call it's very
good book called the rise and fall of
violent crime in America and he talked
about the fact that there's a huge huge
violent crime spike in the United States
in the mid-1980s and it only ended in
about 1994 from 1994 to 2010 there was
an enormous violent crime decrease get
problem is that abortion was the the top
coterie of people who commit crimes are
people between the ages of 14 and 20
that is that is the key age where people
commit crimes and what you see is that
abortion was legalized in 1973 what you
would assume then is that the crime
rates would begin to drop in the late
80s and they begin to drop in like 1987
right that's when people who had been
born but word would have turned 14 or 15
years old
right but that's not what happened the
the crime rates only began to drop in
1994 1995 coincident with something
Hillary Clinton ran away from her
husband's crackdown on crime and once
you put more cops on the streets and put
people in jail for crime it turns out
they're not on the streets to commit
crime so the correlation doesn't
actually fit so the idea that that's the
case it also doesn't make sense because
the fact is that the number of abortions
has decreased markedly over the last 10
or 15 years and you haven't seen a
consummate spike in crime so abortion
rates started to decrease by the mid 90s
and so you would figure there had been a
big spike in crime around 2008-2009 no
big spike in crime so the correlation
doesn't even fit if you're gonna you
know cause it correlation does not equal
causation but in order for there to be
causation there has to at least be some
proof of correlation there's not even
proof of correlation that's my question
my question was more or less what is the
reason why there's such a distant amount
of single mothers in the after makin
poverty like in that realm of because
okay so the real reason that there's a
lot of single motherhood in the black
community is because single motherhood
has increased tremendously across all
communities so it used to be that in
1965 percent of white women were single
mothers today it's 40 percent of white
women so all across it's it's increased
single motherhood and the black
community's been a bigger problem than
in the white community because yes of
pathologies of slavery that goes all the
way back to you know back in slave times
the the the rate of single motherhood
was really high because of forcible
separation of families and that carried
her into Jim Crow as well although it
was beginning to decline actually in the
1950s in the 1940s and 1950s with the
explosion of welfare which was directly
targeted at low-income communities which
happened to be disproportionately
minority now there was an actual
economic incentive to continue in in
pathologies of single motherhood that if
you were thinking about getting married
before you had the baby now maybe didn't
think quite as hard about it because
after all the government was there to
pick you up and so the single motherhood
rate continues to rise at a very high
rate but it's rising similarly at a high
rate in the white community too so I
don't want to pretend it's solely a
black problem single motherhood it isn't
there's a very high single motherhood
rate in the black community high rate in
the white community high rate in the
Hispanic community that's mainly because
of the sexual revolution and the ideas
from the left that a child doesn't need
a mother and a father and that there's
some sort of inherent virtue that
attends to being a single mother which
is really an irritating thing there's a
lot more virtue that it tends to being a
responsible mother marrying dad and then
there being two parents there to help
raise the kid it's a it's a source of
never-ending annoyance to me that the
way the popular culture treats disparate
situations is that my wife who's
responsible enough to get married wait a
few years have a job have kids that that
in the in the heroism pantheon it's she
is secondary to the to the girl who
decided to get pregnant out of wedlock
at 19 and live in poverty no they just
does make any good decisions should be
rewarded by society and the solution is
okay so the ones who've already had kids
are the ones who have not had kids yet I
know I'm asking you are you talking
about the ones who have kids already or
the ones who don't have kids already
okay so the ones who have kids already
the solution is that we have to have a
social network that is built up for them
and that can't be provided by government
okay that needs to be provided by a
growing charitable Association base it
needs to be it needs to be attended to
by a religious community a huge
percentage of black communities still
goes to churches those churches should
take a heavy role in encouraging
marriage and they should take a heavy
role in helping people pick up after
themselves once life mistakes have been
made and I think that many of those
churches are working on that but those
mistakes cannot be unmade by society
just by handing people checks because
all that does is prolonged
so well you really do have to do is help
as you have to have family members that
help you have to have a social network
that helps you out and that's gonna be
rebuilt over a course of time it's not
there's no immediate solution if I'm not
gonna pretend that I have an immediate
turnkey solution for a single mom who
made a lot of mistakes is living in
poverty and now I'm gonna turn her into
a millionaire overnight I can't do that
the government can't do that no one can
do that the government can't take my
money and give it to her and make her
wealthy the government can't take your
responsible okay the fact is that
individual decisions matter even after
you've made a bad one thank you okay
well thank you so much I really
appreciate your time
[Music]